- I also wanted to bring this up too,
because our friend, Ariana Grande,
she's playing you in Glinda.
- Yes. She is! (claps)
- Yeah as Glinda in Wicked.
- Yes! Yes!
- The movie.
So, did she call you for advice?
Like, have y'all talked?
- She didn't call me for advice.
She was really nervous.
She said, I wanna pay homage
to you, but I'm scared.
I don't want you-
I don't, I wanna make you proud.
I go, well, you've already made me proud
so it doesn't matter.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
You've, check, done that.
- That's achieved.
- Yeah.
What I wanna encourage you to do, Ariana,
is make Glinda your Glinda.
Sure, you can tap, tip your hat at me
if you want, but really,
I just want you to do you.
I don't know why I'm so emotional today.
Because I've known her since she was 10.
- I was gonna say, yeah,
'cause you've known her
since she was a little baby.
- Yes. And now I see the full circle.
- And you know the full circle for her.
I found, I was with her when
she found out and she was crying.
- [Kristen] Yeah.
- There was a cake for it.
She was like, it was like,
one of her biggest dreams to do this.
- Biggest dreams.
And she called me, she said,
"I got it!"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I was like, and we sound like dolphins.
I'm like, "you did? Oh my god!"
She goes like, "I did, I did!"
I was like, "What? What? What?"
I mean, it's just, two dolphins talking.
- (laughs) That does sound like dolphins.
- But I'm so proud of her.
And she calls me and she said,
this is what I got to do today.
And what do you think of that?
And I'm just, I'm just so proud of her.
I can't wait to see her do it.
- I know, it's gonna be like
an out-of-body experience for you though.
- It is.
- Just bringing that role to life.
- I'm so-
- You know?
- I can't wait.
- Yeah.
I love the original.
I'm excited to see what they're gonna do
- Me too.
- with the character, because they've,
they've lived for so long,
so it's gonna be exciting to see.
- I know.
- And I just love that it's, it's Ariana
and like, what you mean to her
and what it means to,
it's just a really cool thing
when something like that happens in life
and it's special.
- No, cause you know that-
- and she appreciates it.
- She does.
- Yeah.
- She does. And she'll, she just said
"I'm gonna be freaking out.
Kristen, I'm gonna be freaking out
the night of the premier!"
Maybe she doesn't do it with that
- She does that little voice? (laughs)
- She does. Maybe she'll do
the accent, but she's like,
"I'm really scared!"
I'm like, stop. I'm like, stop.
You're gonna be great.
Like, my boyfriend's like, "you two!"
- Why did your voice change with her? Yes.
(both laughing)